there was it there was a gay dude at my
high school - that was kind of like that
but he would just be like you look like
[ __ ] straight people like you in the
hallways like he'd have [ __ ] straight
boys like straight people pissed me off
like that it's like what the [ __ ] dude
like that's you're making people dislike
you yeah that's not you like make
friends dude that's how it is in high
school though right like kids get so
[ __ ] put in their box and they
believe that's like the only way to look
at everything and high school just have
to resent everybody kids man there was
his other dude his name was Nathan I
actually knew this kid from my previous
elementary school before the one that
got removed from it was were stabbing
someone in the face yeah I think yeah
let's move on from that
this kid Nathan very interesting kid he
actually moved to Alaska
not two while ago and he became a pastor
but I remember this kid because he was
suffering from depression now I didn't
know what depression was I just thought
it was sadness yeah okay
but I remember he just kept talking
about his depression to everybody right
which I know like go for a walk I don't
have a [ __ ] this kid was so [ __ ]
weird because he would tell everybody
about his depression all the time and I
just remembered looking into his ear
cavity and it had earwax just coming I
was like maybe you're depressed because
you can't hear anything yeah start with
that no I said but I sick burn that's a
good burn I didn't know about the
[ __ ] depression and he goes and we
started getting into a little argument
because he kept on trying to talk me
about the [ __ ] and mind you I was really
nice too because I remember him from
elementary school so I want to saw him
in high school I was like I remember
he's that the elementary weird kid right
and I think we were friends as
elementary students but he became a
little weird and he was just talking
about depression to everybody I remember
one time I just looked at him he just
goes he goes David like I'm just so
depressed I was like bro I don't give a
[ __ ] got so irritated and I was like go
do something about it right and that he
looks at me hey mind you I'm a lot older
than you know about depression it wasn't
a huge time reminisce and he looks at me
and he goes he goes it's a chemical
imbalance and I remember I looked at him
and I was like you're a [ __ ] loser
and I left that and I just walked away
yeah that was a very terrible this just
shows how mean kids can be in high
school and how they can make a change
recipe statement he's out in Alaska he's
a pastor he wife he has a kid
he's killing he actually moved to
another state because of me but I think
he kind of leveled himself out the
problem was like in high school there
was a lot of guys I guess during that
time whatever they found it was like
that emo Rock stage no people were all
getting to their feelings in it I think
everybody has that during high school
because now we have email rap so during
my time it was emo Rock and so they
listen to this music at all all up in
there [ __ ] feeling start writing
poetry and poems but there was like a
bunch of losers expressing their
feelings right Emel right guys yeah yeah
yeah and so we've been there we've all
been there and that's probably why your
dad asked you that question I remember
there's this other kid whose name was
Jeremy and the reason why I couldn't
take like depression seriously because
there was a certain amount of group of
kids that kind of and there's always
people like this that takes something
that's very serious and they try to use
it for their advantage and that's kids
in high school dude kids that should all
yeah you would always call people's
Bluffs this kid Jeremy he would try to
use a depression thing to get girls to
talk to him just be like oh are you okay
are you fine and he would like talk to
them after school so I remember one time
now mind you I didn't handle this very
well either cuz I was already fed up
with this because Nathan there talked to
me about his depression for weeks
yeah and I had this other kid named
Jeremy and a lot of the girls were
getting irritated of him because he
would hop from different girls within
the group because a girl would catch on
like oh he's just using this so he could
talk to me so I could be his girlfriend
they would cut him out then he'd go to
another one then another one day and so
I was good so I did not handle the
very well either if it was very serious
I did not do this very well at all
because this kid finally it got to my
ears that he was quote-unquote depressed
and I remember he wrote on AIM as a
group chat he just goes you know what
guys I'm just gonna go and drink